come aft the total ethos again oh hey
wait um hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to a dark place I
didn't click on anything ye olde wake up
scene I suppose okay Oh ty I take a
cautious step forward friends need to
play the music box well since I got
nothing better to do with my existence I
guess I'll press E to play the music box
that's nice
no no that's a slice of something
special yeah I immediately regret
everything it was so nice now it's not
nice hello jammed well I guess I don't
have to worry about anyone breaking
alright you want some of this if you
want it oh wow hi hello how are you my
name is markiplier okay goodbye
o ye olde wake up sequence jana rama
hope there's a music box around here
main lobby oh okay
tell me what this is about with his
pretty cool not so bad
hello room one okay sure
chapter one fear I don't like the name
of that chapter table don't better go
ahead and protest against that that
seems oh uh I'm sorry excuse me excuse
me excuse me are you just running on a
loop
are you the train of fear listen for the
train to pass oh well you've got a face
on you oh hey you take pretty wide turns
there I don't like that okay oh I do
love this jamming soundtrack what am I
gonna hold is this a timeout chair is
this the naughty corner help I've been
bad somebody punished me in the naughty
corner okay so why was that there okay
well I'll push every mysterious button
that I come across oh all right okay so
I'm supposed to be opening something
well so far this isn't a very fearful
chapter so far it seems to be mundane
and full of button pressing and has a
cool train to this wait
[Music]
okay I think whoa wait where rhythm hell
what's up
what the fresh hell hey hey whoa aah
bargain
I broke the odd broke the goddamn game
oh my god okay all right then I don't
know what happened there Oh Oh fan our
yeah well hey listen I'm uh Oh game
crash has occurred failed to find level
game over at 360 Denise solutions
restart the game and try again
error code brittle at some reason I
don't believe you oh my oh okay alright
trying again I guess we're gonna load it
back up and see what the dealio is I
guess runaway play game okay was that a
real crash or was that just a fakie
crash Oh welcome to my place in this
game you the player will create this
place and explore the environment you
have created this wonderful adventure
game features wonderful graphics and
design all created through imagination
now before we begin we must first create
a universe okay why didn't I get this
boot for I don't know why this is
happening now oh hey I love watching you
you sure do
I've picked up on that idea
okay all right I'll do it what did you
say buddy Oh Oh what the hacking hell
what happened this was a completely
different game before hi oh you found me
you found me you found me what's
happening he's it like every time you
load up the game it's a different game
is that what the game is hey I was going
on here
created by our Studios you have that's
the same oh I didn't hit anything I'm
back again I guess okay all right I I
don't fully understand but we're going
back into chapter 1 of fear and that's
good I guess
right chugalug chugalug all right so is
the button already pressed for the first
one then because if it is then that's
good easy whoa hey buddy oh it's not
whoa
listen we'll have already done that okay
let's go into the other room I hope it
has an equally interesting Paul okay bye
that's weird not a hundred percent sure
what's going on here but seems like the
game is distinctly trying to dick with
me
and I am a man who cannot be dict with
through six years of doing these horror
games I don't think that it's in any way
possible for me to be [ __ ] with okay
so that lit up one of those but will it
light up the others the question or will
I be able to even exit the door again is
there gonna be another discipline chair
over here another naughty corner Oh
oh what a lovely ottoman a box oh what's
in the box
I don't want to know what's in the box
okay let's try to go through the door
again and see if that'll actually
for me here we go wait for the Train oh
wait this is this isn't the door this
isn't oh yeah that's right there's
another train here okay chocolate
chocolate
man you're speedy I don't want to go
where it's going I know that some of you
were like God follow the train but I'm I
wasn't listening I wasn't listening I
was not listening I'm good I'm okay I'm
okay I wasn't listening but I'm okay
through sheer luck and magnanimous I'm
fine good good good good great
everything's cool I love the music it's
real Bop the real Bop it's a good Bob Oh
what did you see how much I loved the
music oh okay there we go
the BOP is back baby there we go okay we
made it through okay oh whoa Oh requires
a key huh okay well what's over here
okey how perfect for me key a baton ed
requires different key okay well I know
where this one goes
but don't look at me weird oh okay go
through here oh yay
I'm here now oh hi nice plant
why why why is it one choice that's just
a very normal thing in the air other
choices just what I actually need it Wow
another key and a lovely painting I have
no idea but it's a lovely game yep what
I didn't hear it it sounded like it was
far away or my ears broken was that
supposed to happen my heart let's try it
again I guess
whoa oh I thought that cloud was the
face those getting closer okay that was
that was paranoia on my part I'm trying
my damndest what the hell
son of a [ __ ] here we go again I don't
like being in this quote/unquote dark
place but I'm gonna get out of here I'm
thinking maybe there's like a specific
order that you have to do this [ __ ]
maybe that's the only thing I could
guess I think it's like if you even
touch the Train things go very badly for
you
good golly I don't know what the deal is
with you when you're rounding those
corners you really like to swing that
ass out I get it I understand if you got
it flaunt it why not but just don't
flaunt it in my face please just let me
progress to the next area please there
we go get the key it was a nice key
let's wait for that let's not wait let's
play hot and heavy huh
shouldn't have played it hot and heavy
oh hey it's a chrysanthemum huh okay
alright I thought I died I just guessed
okay can I be done with the tray oh my
god you love watching me okay what I
supposed to listen for a train there you
love watching me oh great oh great all
right oh alt f4 detected what is that
[Music]
oh oh oh oh no oh oh that's creepy
that's legitimately terrifying okay all
done then okay you're done
all right cool great good to know thank
you for stopping by
oh here we go then I get the joke oh
[ __ ] what what is that what am I looking
at here contact my place
nightmare wants to play weebly.com okay
well we got a picture of a smiling face
with a banana mouth so that's nice
I've saved that image in the place where
you save those things you gonna do
anything else is there any other process
running okay all right let's load the
game back up there's fun whoa Oh
meathooks
oh no it's like that scene from Sponge
Bob does this look dangerous to you the
answer is of course it doesn't in no way
does this look in any way dangerous oh
[ __ ] okay
like I said those do look dangerous to
you absolutely not gonna have you what
are you oh I can go no further
hmm okay I'll go the other way turn my
back to you which is a good idea okay
nevermind then I guess this is all we
have just a bunch of fish hooks hanging
from the ceiling and you use Styria and
piece of [ __ ] oh you think you're better
than me huh
apparently you think you're better than
me
okay Oh funky funky clunky what happens
if I go this way nothing I can't go that
way
but I was too smart for you you thought
that you could trick me it turns out
that you can not trick me
I'm on trickable I'm unkillable too I'm
unbreakable I'm unstoppable
I'm the best there ever was on the
definition of magnanimous whatever that
means
oh hello Oh music box
oh I'm the face bashing through the MOE
selected music box of fear it is now
stored in your data folder alright time
to go down this long I'm gonna Solway do
you think I should go where should I do
it everything's a joke here
[Music]
that's not good
that's one of you that's you oh I'll bet
the game was trying to open and close my
cd-rom okay all right music one music
box of fear let's play this bad boy or
not okay well that doesn't make any
sense but okay
it won't open the thing I can't open my
test manager either oh oh my computer's
crashing OH
uh-huh well I can't do anything well
everything seems to be completely frozen
Oh something happened ah server
execution cool okay that's fine
can I play the game again oh there's
task manager try it again
oh that looks more broken than it was
before
still got that laughs I see you got a
friendly sense of humor is there gonna
be there all the time now but we just
gonna live with this laughs this is what
we're doing oh hey
were you the one laughing okay all right
well we got the music box of fear though
still got this goddamn laugh all right
you know what I'm gonna kill this laugh
do you think you're better than me huh
oh my god okay um here we go and get
hecka ah killed the laugh there we go
you think you're better than me huh
you think you're better than me huh you
are not you are not better than me let's
go to room two whatever you got Oh Oh
boohoo
I made you stop laughing Oh buddy Hootie
hoo hoo
know what'll get here this is a toilet
snack time okay lovely paintings you
have on the wall here oh well oh [ __ ]
hey y'all gonna charging you hey hey
listen
oh I don't know about that one I don't
know who to trust
if there's anybody to trust about all
this okay ah a lovely mirror I can
finally see myself well this place looks
promising okay what have you got for me
what is this a key
excellent I love key where does key go
and why do I have a bad feeling about
key well only one way to go whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa you gonna do that again
was that just a one-time thing and why
were you coming from the left that's
where the X was there goes okay go go go
go go go go go yes yes yes honka-honka I
didn't like how oh you loved watch you
turn back no I'm good oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay Oh Oh ma'am you no you
no no no no you no no how about a whole
lot of no oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
that was close dude if I turned around
they would have probably ended badly for
me oh [ __ ] okay well now I'm here
wherever the hell here is and whyever
the hell here I am here what's down
there I don't trust it what's down there
I trust it less but I'm going for it Oh
huh well I don't know the code so Oh
why um why you do noise now
why would you do noise now Oh the code
is in my face all along okay I don't
know the code so oh [ __ ] unlocks in nine
eight well shitty oh oh well ain't this
a problem
oh whoa I don't you know I did oh oh
I hid a code in one of your folders on
this computer the folders name starts
with docume in documents search for doc
you doc um do come searching for do come
out it's just in documents okay well
that's easy enough
okay pass through door dad easy easy
your trick po8 631 got it okay all right
okay eight six three one it is then
where am i this is not where I was
no need to go back well whatever you say
man eight six three one this looks
different this looks different
does it look dear friend am I crazy okay
all right here we go 8 6 3 1 enter oh
thank you thank you I'm free I am free I
[Music]
don't trust that even remotely for a
second oh look it's a bloody tunnel down
into the abyss alright man I love the
way that this game is just messing with
you that's oh [ __ ] that's a pretty this
is pretty incredible but like the level
of Ditka tree that this game is going
through like it's almost like a virus on
your computer I wouldn't be surprised if
the guy who who made this game or the
girl or whoever made this game whatever
team like if they got inspiration from
know some viruses okay I'll go in the
music room hi sorry oh hey hey come on
now don't be shy come on play a little
guitar play a little piano
picture-taking room I love taking
pictures
oh are you currently using a webcam
sadly I am not do I have a webcam ah
tactically but not really no are you
lying
no-no-no not lying why would I lie to
all oh well if you don't have a webcam
that I guess we cannot do one journey
picture equals one key go to the
terminal and type command give key the
key goes to the recording room well I
could go get a webcam okay I got I go go
get well I'll go get a webcam I'll go I
guess I'll just go then okay what oh
[ __ ] oh oh oh oh all right I'll leave
this to you guys um I don't know what
the hell's happening here but you guys
I'm gonna go get it I'm gonna go get oh
I'm gonna go get a webcam you guys stay
here
[Music]
and he's spooky scary things webcam in
place I can't wait to see where this
goes oh boy here we go go oh oh okay
here we go again I have a webcam am I
currently using a webcam the answer is
yes yes I am
we are about to take your picture of
your journey pictures are stored in the
memory and will be deleted after you
leave the picture and since you told me
it's currently being used it must be
temporarily turned off for this to work
after you're done you can turn it back
on whatever you want continue yes
go yeah oh I wasn't ready did you take
it too far is you okay did you take it
well I wasn't but I didn't bye oh this
oh I already knew about this we saw this
okay
back and it to win it now ha the picture
room whoa okay press e when ready oh oh
now I'm taking it yay oh hey how's it
going
all right okay all right okay all right
okay I'm ready I'm ready hang on let me
line her up we good guys uh no I wasn't
ready okay
five four did it do it
did it work is that them
so let me oh well I didn't that didn't
it didn't work three five four
[Music]
did it work I I worked hard to get this
webcam here there we go we got it
hell yeah all right I'm ready does it
work got ten a damn bow do this right to
me you better do right by me
come on I know it maybe maybe Walt what
I alt f4 that was supposed to be
something right I think I got a restart
the the program okay let's try this
again I may have to start over from a
place but I'm gonna make this work I
ain't gonna pussyfoot about this I'm
gonna make this work damn it oh good
here we are did it work how do I make
you work how do I make you work it's
working
I see me why is it not working wait I
think I think what it is is it's trying
to use the camera that you're seeing me
on right now as it's so I'm going to
stop recording for a moment and then
come back because I think that's what
it's doing and it can't use it it can't
use it if I'm using it so I'll be right
back it'll be fine don't worry okay so I
might be gone but I'm not gone gone so
let's see if this make the difference
because it might be trying to do that it
might be trying to do that and if it's
trying to do that that's good so I'll
you I'm not here I'm not here but you
might see me in the game maybe if it
actually is a game it's like the old
style let's place where a face camelus
let's place here we do
let's do this I'm ready take it okay
all right damn it tit ass [ __ ] and balls
okay that didn't work either all right
I'm back now okay I don't think I can
get this to work I have no idea how to
get this to work actually I have one
more idea okay
I'm back I restarted my computer because
I'm thinking that maybe it wouldn't have
been in the registry as a webcam and
when it needed to be so now I've got it
so let's see if it actually works
[Music]
wait it lit up oh that's good enough you
know that's good enough genuine surprise
that's good okay I got my picture it
finally worked I don't think that was
even remotely worth all the effort now I
have that Oh a key good for me
all right I got a key now what do I do
with it
that was a lot of effort for very little
work okay it requires key but not this
key I bet all right so recording room
enter mm-hmm okay it's a lot play set up
Hey it's what's me look at that
it's my face oh that's so weird ah ah
look at you
oh look at me oh good thing we got our
picture taken okay big boulder you all
right what do I do now what else way are
you gonna mess with me I do love this
though I do love all the intricacies
that it's got going for it all the
different ways to mess with me that's so
cool Oh what is that over there but it
makes my skin crawl and I love it hello
I have a key did I use the key already
hello I thought I had a key but
apparently I don't have a key anymore I
don't like the door to let those but the
hell you think you're doing with those
totally dues you don't totally do
I got key then all right so I can unlock
the tail cells
something tells me I don't want to do
that but here I go doing it exactly that
anyway Oh what plush carpeting for a
jail cell
I got a music box key okay
I missed the Dooley deuce
I wish the Dooley dudes were back I kind
of missed the door delitos can I have
the totally throws again currently no
hey ho ass [ __ ] [ __ ] you fine
I didn't know what to do about that you
found me good good for you good oh good
great okay it's getting toasty in here
what are you gonna do huh
just guys I couldn't currently not
possible screw you whatever this game is
bonkers though in a good way in such a
good way this game is boy why here
now what'd you do oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh
[ __ ] okay well I didn't go in there okay
wait a minute the door wait the door
unlocks maybe I only need the key on
that door to be able to get through
there I think that's why that must have
been what it was this is so cool
I mean it's a bit [ __ ] ish sometimes
but you know that's fine because it's
it's I'm learning okay
it's almost circle round we're gonna go
back oh maybe not okay here we go we're
gonna make a bigger loop we're gonna
make a bigger loop big loop big loop big
big bouncy loop okay let's go come on
what am I supposed to do about that it's
like you have to wait anyway man that's
it but how do you do that I'm going a
long way around let's see if I go around
this my cut through here oh oh the
portal right Oh
music one reel oh it's much worse oh
it's much worse are the walls jiggling a
little bit yeah okay Wow Oh jammed oh
that dog clean dirty clean dirty okay
all right okay ah oh hey okay what does
that say where's your wet webcam where's
your webcam what I mean is it's right
there still accessible smile you're on
video camera I don't know it's it's
available you could use it if you want
not you again
oh good you're gone click music box of
sadness now stored in your data folder
No thank you for that thank you very
much for that
I appreciate that greatly
okay music room fake I see I see a rat
well can i oh I can't go through this
anymore so I'll just uh be on my way oh
great okay alright so uh to tootling why
is the - what is it - to DeLand sound
like it's chasing me why is it -
doodling getting louder you don't need
to poo pood all that hard
oh I don't have wheel that's still
another wheel okay you're forgetting
something am i you don't know that maybe
I'm realizing something realizing that I
shouldn't be tramping around in this
house longer I didn't forget something
easy peasy I don't know what this does
but there I go whatever that is I sure
did that
Oh Oh jump easy-peasy
Oh oh wow okay why though but why but
why but why though but why am I gonna
get anywhere chapter ii finished oh good
you didn't thank you okay I guess is
that a good thing is there something
though boy oh boy thank you oh oh oh no
flash flash oh oh oh there I go well
there I go I'm I'm off I guess I'm just
doing its own thing I guess
Oh darkness my old friend okay all right
well oh one I saw one I like one anyway
so did you have fun did you had fun your
grammars [ __ ] no oh oh well that's a
lovely desktop I liked my other one
though so if you could give that back
that'd be great
all right back into it I suppose I
suppose back into it all right oh wow a
dark place yes you're even more Cerf
onkled Yahoo let's do this
let's wait them up let's do it let's go
I wonder what debug mode is one day I'm
gonna try that ah oh okay
oh oh it's all better now
okay the little room three tears I said
that kind of like sadness isn't that
kind of like sadness he could have
gotten axed to see your joy or for anger
or something like that I don't know I
don't know what you're trying to go for
tears isn't exactly an emotion but I'm
ready for it whatever it is
hello okay what have you got for me
hello is it a boss is it's still a train
oh okay easy peasy dorkness
okay well it was a whole lot of nothing
in there maybe there was something and I
just couldn't see it which is entirely
possible what's down here hello
oh god no a flashlight that would make a
lot of sense okay so whatever was in
that room I definitely needed my phone
off requires key okay whatever you say
Oh can't go that way it's unfinished I
don't want to see the game unfinished
okay so there must be something in this
room that he's worth seeing turn off
lights I want to be surprised here we go
three two one oh now I can go good thing
I didn't go down here and get lost
before maybe it did that intentionally
until I got the flashlight which would
be good game design oh okay
dear traveler to proceed here you must
enter the real verse to unlock this
passage there should be a portal nearby
in this current location sincerely thank
you I see that you died with the
Olympics in your heart can you get out
of my face q thank you requires key okay
so real verse I'm guessing you mean the
real world by that is that what you're
saying hmm well I don't know what that
means so let me explore the rest of this
area before I move on and try to explore
the deeper levels of my files Oh
potatoes or rocks potatoes are these
potatoes
why does my framerate go down here
potatoes turds what am I looking at okay
well don't know what the point of this
area was okay well it's just a weird
room full of rocks
sure all right well there's something in
the quote unquote real verse but before
I go there let me check the right side
of this room out here it seemed like
there might be something out there I
mean this game is so full of goddamn
nooks and crannies and secrets something
happened on my other monitor
[Music]
something happened I saw something okay
so what did it say about the real verse
there was a bit of a clue there was a
bit of a clue there travela the pottery
but after the rail buck to unlock those
magnet there should be a portal nearby
in this current location a portal nearby
in this current location so where is
this current location if we're thinking
about this we've got four rings four
flowers
what does this mean sonic I'm thinking
sonic I see rings I think sonic acquires
keycard okay I don't have a key card
that's for damn sure
the only thing I'm finding is this
message here hello are you there I'm a
person trapped within the game my file
has been corrupt and is stored somewhere
in the game files do not enter the empty
room this is where I'm located things
may go very wrong if you do so but if
repeated just continue forward okay all
right okay also here's the various other
files that caused my computer to go a
little wonky
oh wait whoa what am I looking at Oh oh
my god
that was oh my god I could only see that
with my light off holy [ __ ] that was
impossible to see oh geez
that was tiny all right whatever please
tell me this here okay what oh my god ah
finally progress I was fiddling around
for too long how's the portal we yeah we
we did it whatever it was we did it oh
ah currently in real yeah you know what
I don't like the real verse something
tells me the real verse is kind of
[ __ ]
real verse is real goopy - oh this is
the that's the that's that's the rocks
oh hey bloody how you doing okay okay oh
you doing are you doing there friendos
Oh delightful
okay um mmm Jam but can I headbutt these
eyeballs so there was something here but
now there's nothing seems like this
could move seems like there's something
here that definitely could move so
either there's a button or something
that I'm missing ah we can go through
here oh oh that's that's lovely oh my
god that is just a lovely wall of faces
I remember that from like doom or
something like that that might actually
be the texture from doom when you were
actually in hell there was a wall I
recognize that I can't believe I
recognized that holy [ __ ] that's the
wall from doom oh my god that's so cool
sorry
it's geeked out the original doom
believe it or not that is the wall of
faces from one of the hell levels of
doom holy [ __ ]
all right now that opened up a basilar
way over here did we need to go
somewhere else
Oh what is that okay oh I don't like
this cutscene and to the goop I guess
that's it I just hoppity hippity DUP go
okay okay what am I doing here
and why am i doing it can I be out of
the horrible can I go back to the real
or the other fake I took the fake over
the real any day but only in this
circumstance Oh oh hi hello orbiting D
20s this whole place is masked up where
am I now am I even supposed to be here I
don't even know oh good a key right a
key I've got a key where the hell does
this key go and why did I have to go all
the way this way and the real to get it
also why is the real soul
oh this is open now okay all right
nothing over there okay this makes very
little sense but I'm here in a minute
so whatever you got to show oh boy I'll
cook off any of eyeballs okay hmm
okay so this is where a portal would be
but now there's just a hole in the wall
so guess I'll go in another hole in the
wall keep going and random holes in the
walls I can't really can't really run
here can't use my flashlight either I'm
kind of just stuck to a slow walk okay I
don't know why no this seems bad going
down the interdimensional butt hole that
is this tunnel can't run something's
gonna happen
Oh something's got lights going up nope
something's gonna happen
music oh now oh I see something at the
end of the hallway I don't think I'm
gonna like it but I see it okay I'm not
looking behind me no matter what you say
oh it's blue Dookie
Oh way whoa
nightmare rat injecting to computer Oh
God
great welcome onboard
there you go receiving input good there
it is that's great
Wow that is really nice that is really
nice
okay let us send message odds
dear cobot boink okay got that good
advance okay not advanced settings open
web browser set to URL google.com ok
oh this computer has been locked by your
administrator okay that seems good thank
you for that probably for my own good
you know to be perfectly honest no
advance setting this okay disconnect oh
[ __ ]
maybe now is not the best night okay all
right
jiggly oh error gray Oh lots of error
gray Oh
murder what did you say you said
something huh uh oh I was in the middle
of closing windows oh well oh hi hello
how are you okay can you stop lagging my
computer out that'd be great
okay close close close all right
everything's fine though we're good to
go
all right close that let's close this
loader back up I'm sure it'll be in a
good place and I'm sure I'll love every
minute of it let's play the game
Zaire studios hi hello welcome to the
party oh good all right ain't that
lovely ain't that lovely okay well oh
whoa Nelly
Oh Oh easy Oh I'm super fast now okay
run I'm just gonna keep going this is
gonna go through the light at the end of
the tunnel probably somebody oh wait no
that's not a light at the end of the oh
that is a face I'm gonna dodge you whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa you've been
caught
[Music]
well game over apparently okay well I
didn't know that's the game we were
playing let's try this again baby come
on
you think I'm done that easily screw you
and screw your face and screw your face
twice as harder as I screw you come on
baby
oh no it's deuce again okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna dance a lot that
can jump dog can jump real high okay so
whatever I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is
I'm not gonna look at you I don't know
if there's only so far to go over that
way come here baby doink you can't catch
me
like the ginger oh oh [ __ ] get out of
here I think I got to go back the other
way back the way I came because
otherwise I'm just gonna be stuck in a
circle all right come on buddy come on a
friend pop nope I'm out I'm out I'm out
you can't catch me I'm too fast I'm too
fast for you I don't know what you're
saying
looks like it might be in Russian but I
can't even understand that little in
English so I'll a portal whee Oh
did that work okay I think it worked yay
I don't know what it worked doing but it
worked
Oh currently in the fake well thank
goodness I didn't even want to be in the
real to begin with I was stuck in there
for so long look at that for years man I
wish I was fast as I wasn't the real
real I was super speedy okay so did I do
it did I did I done sit okay I got a key
I don't know what the key goes to it's
not a key card hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey listen [ __ ]
you think I'm gonna scared that easily
the answer is no I'm Way too brave for
you there was another door with another
key required over here I think good to
know that the real is bleeding over into
the fake whatever the real and fake is
so fake to me okay trash okay good to
know
I like trash that's where I belong I
love this though I real I'm said it
before but I love this is because it
like bleeds this air of
of being less than what it seems it
looks like any other like randomly made
indie horror game but you can tell that
there's so much work poured into this
one so much care so much love so many
scares so goodness this is super fun
it's always a it's always a treat to
come across a game like this that really
pushes things to another level like it
takes the whole concept of messing with
you on your computer to a completely
different level and I love the keycard I
needed this okay good but what's over
here a box was a drawer what's in the
drawer I got the key card oh okay a
train station oh wait no don't don't
don't don't leave directly to the train
station as in the rails go there also
why is this one locked this one's locked
but why would it exist in the first
place don't like it don't like it was
this room so big before wait wait a
minute
oh no it was there's the trash okay
that's good I got the key okay oh okay
all right okay everything did I put put
it there we go
okay good oh wow nice art hello can I
have a one-pass please thank you
Percy to read I can't read this oh it
appears you are using a none activated
version of dark place to receive your
activation key please contact this blow
support email with a message asking for
the key you will be presented with an
activation key and I'll receive a
passcode to the door to unlock the
forest
okay be serious okay
so I'll send an email okay I sent it
okay that email did nothing oh wait here
we go we got a response the activation
code we have it all right we have it
that did that worked oddly enough man
some programming went into this thing I
mean it's not hard to make an email
system that responds but that's cool
still okay oh wow
Slendy man are you out there you out
there Slendy man oh boy
classic classic stuff that's the
fascinating thing about this game you
can see there who's made using like
stock assets but what what makes it what
makes it special is that it was crafted
together in such an impeccable way I've
always said like it's it's not about the
graphics of the game it's not about like
the music of the game cuz the music at
the game is particularly good it's like
rehash royalty-free classical music but
like just the packaging
just the sheer balls of this game that's
what makes it something special this is
like so nice to see because it's just
like oh man people can do so much if
they just put their mind to something if
they don't just make something face on
just jump-scares and I mean this game
has jump scares but if you just make
something that you put your heart and
soul into you can make so much cool
stuff you can make so much cool stuff oh
man
that's what this this game really makes
me really makes me like oh hey how's it
going grandma you home hey grandma
grandma Oh what do you see there what is
that something's on the screen left loft
roofed
Lufton is there a back door maybe
this ship this one's just plain old rock
okay all right had to done the only
other path that I could possibly follow
hey a barn okay sure
can I pass through this can I jump
locked okay I couldn't possibly get
around that fence there's just no way
every other place in this entire area
has been deserted I don't know if
jumping makes me go any faster in fact
I'm pretty sure it doesn't it just feels
like I'm doing something so I do it
anyway
hello everything's locked why is
everything locked where do I go no now
this is good now there's piss me off
because now I have no idea where to go
and do I have to backtrack back and
forth until I find it is there some
obscure key hidden in a [ __ ] bush is
that what we got going on here is that
what I got a hunt for oh [ __ ]
oh come on at least make me go super
speed oh oh my god oh my god is there
something in the middle of this don't
know if there's not oh there is oh my
god ah of course I am a stupid that is
the first place I went and I didn't see
the goddamn key on the ground well
wouldn't you know about that oh maybe
there's gonna actually open up this
place first cuz it seemed like the
logical progression of things to go to
and therefore I was the stupid because I
didn't do it right no it doesn't come
really it doesn't go to this one god
damn it alright fine then I'll backtrack
maybe hey vo yo uh-huh okay alright
what's in the barn now another key now
the question is what place does this
unlock well we're near here so we might
as well try this first right my guess is
this actually opens up the the the house
and it's all this backtracking is
intentional to make me off guard so you
can jump scare me later huh isn't it
yeah it's the house oh boy Ben got it
okay and then lost oh hi reading lost
Iowa
okay what is lost is this loss darkness'
emulator okay
lost okay hi internet requested
currently using internet connection
okay Oh successfully connected to server
one dark - wired.com okay
I trust that that seems legit I'm down
to clown for that please take all of my
data steal all my videos do I was that
connection to game servers been denied
server may be down and maintenance or
you may not have internet try again
later but I want it but I want it whoa
blue-winged warning all blueing objects
have been destroyed and some time has
passed but the connection has been left
open in the background unused and still
connected if this is intended behavior
disabled the timeout warning and the
object parameters if you want to close
the application notes
[Music]
was that supposed to happen was it was
it was that supposed to happen was that
swell I don't think that was supposed to
happen I don't think that was supposed
to happen I can't tell if anything
exactly a bugger not or if it's like a
feature of the game right I don't think
it was a click anything here okay okay
blue-winged warning whatever that is it
just crashes but it didn't do this
script crash that it did before what did
it do oh really oh okay just drop the
key on the ground I don't know what that
was all about but okay we got a key
though so carrying on finishing whatever
the hell's going on in this adventure
which honestly I'm not sure of I do not
know all right come here you big gate
whatever you lead to I'm going inside so
don't even try to stop me
okay whoosh I don't know how key cause
the portcullis gate to open up like that
but I'm not gonna question it Slendy man
slender hand where are you no is there
something over there I'm not gonna miss
it this time hello hello
Mel Oh No okay alright little weird
is it just an open path over between the
lights there's a lot of you know walking
I have to do there's a path here it's a
lot of walking that I got to do you can
make it a little more skedaddle II for
me if you made this just a little faster
I could get through this a lot better
maybe no okay alright then
is there anything over here now this
does seem like Slenderman
oh hello tiles newspapers oh alright
suppose the point of that what's over
here was a pillar over there I don't
even know if I'm supposed to go over
there supposed to go anywhere here this
is a big empty land this is like the map
for multiplayer Slenderman
what's nothing it's the block of white
nice nothing okay what the hell I was
just singing this games praises and now
I'm lost in the woods this sequence is a
little asinine a little boring I don't
understand what you want from me I don't
get it am I looking for something
there's not a lot of direction okay
found something but this is stunningly
close I could have just hippity-hop it
over that hill
but alas Here I am okay okay a whole lot
of nothing just a big old dick Rock
right here in the middle of nowhere
Sarki on the ground a key would be
glowing oh okay well that's helpful
no okay suddenly got quiet don't know
why I got quiet okay
hello hi that was a long way to go to
get in
[Music]
excuse me miss but excuse me but excuse
me oh wait a minute okay hang on okay
hang on don't laugh at me you're
laughing at me
whoa hi what the hell all wait wait a
minute
what hi Howard
the help i'ma go this way ah see I got
your number now maybe oh maybe I don't
have your number
oh hi oh okay okay collect the coin okay
no all right then what tinnie what okay
now your lower resolution or why what is
that all about you're gone don't know uh
whoa what the [ __ ] did I just click on
what the hell okay uh-huh
right oh my god what the hell is that
oh wait is that why that note pop back
up
oh do not answer the empty empty room
this is where I'm located thinks I'm
gonna make how very wrong if you do so
if repeated oh this is the room it was
talking about though this is the
repetition room this is the room of
repeating and it's going very wrong so
far I think I might have seen the whole
gambit but I just want to be sure if
there's not some point to this
there's bro ohh oh [ __ ] oh hi hello hi
hi oh oh oh you did warn me okay you did
warn me you did warn me you warned me
about that you did warn me okay you
warned me I didn't listen I'm a fool
shame on me though okay so let's uh
let's just not go in there anymore maybe
one more done just to see what's in
there oh hi y'all right there buddy
oh whoa whoa you're pulling up oh you
are pulling a UH what's his name bendy
Ben Baldy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god damn it
okay well you know I didn't want to be
in here oh [ __ ] there goes my curiosity
okay well oh you're not even uniting the
crash in the game you're just
hello oh hi hello I can't seem to take
this anymore
ah okay all right that's a thing you did
okay all right well this is a lovely
place of hell oh I'm so glad that you
brought me into this hell with you so
that we could be together forever
smiling always smiling at each other so
is there anything that I can do about
this or is this just the way life is at
the moment yep seems like this is just
the way life be are all right see uh-oh
exiting okay hope I don't stay in there
ye how many times have I loaded this
game back up man
and I've been playing this game for like
almost two hours now I didn't think that
it was gonna be this long I had another
list of games not that I'm regretting it
now that I'm regretting at any capacity
this is super cool all right I'm going
no light anymore left ah shitty tits oh
boy okay
well oh boy oh boy yeppity-do da-da-da
same thing let me just make sure it's
the same thing in that I'm gonna keep
going forward
oh you just closed out okay you didn't
even want to deal with me anymore I
understand I understand I get you hey
listen you me I understand you don't
think I understand I understand
okay moving on we're not going back
there anymore let's just move on we're
just gonna keep moving forward I don't
know what that was all about but frankly
I don't need to know I think we're
getting close to the end of the third
chapter and there's only four chapters
so getting closer to the end of the game
oh this easy huh oh wow wait a minute
the music box of tears is now stored in
your data folder okay that's great
oh boy I love this this is good stuff
this is good stuff he got in my face did
I slip into the whoa I think I slipped
into the real there chapter three
finished okay did you know thank you for
that like I said I was getting close and
then I got those [ __ ] turned back
oh whoa okay holy hell anyway I'm not
gonna turn back I'm not gonna do it
anyway I'm gonna downoload up the game
now don't let the corruption stop you I
wasn't gonna holding good ah
I wasn't gonna let the corruption stop
me why would I let the corruption stop
me okay yeah I got a fight there we go
oh come on get in the girl in the game
I'm we're there there's the game play ah
there we go
okay that window is still going Jocelyn
in the background over there
so that's it's gonna be trumpeting its
own a little dune there for a while but
we get room for fists a roomful of fists
vengeance
oh okay vengeance for what and from whom
more specifically vengeance is always
directed towards somebody so you got to
tell me what that flashing
I'm gonna stop that flashing you're
gonna know my god is still going this is
out of the corner of my eye and got him
got him got him I got you don't think
that you're trickier than I am cuz I got
you all right what do we got here
hello okay whoa train I like a deranged
so it's currently set to on me in the
trains moving area one unlocked okay
good that's good right
we want that right that sounds like
something I want to happen okay what is
this
I would it just be a door to go to
another door Oh train
okay do you have a face on you no you're
just a normal train all right we're
gonna hippity hop on the train
Oh oh hell yeah
go oh [ __ ] what what huh I haven't
selected no.1 Oh got it
I have to actually hit one there we go
got it okay so we're going to area one
wherever that is I don't know how many
areas there are but I unlock one of them
and I'm headed off there was probably
another thing in the place where I just
was but I imagine I'll go back there
probably unless I missed it forever and
then this is too bad for me mmm nice
train I like it
chuckle a chuckle Oh indeed okay are we
gonna get there anytime soon are we just
gonna be waiting forever I got a
schedule to keep God I got things to do
people to see
okay still juggling Oh everyone yay
arrived good great thank you
exit the train okay where am I going now
okay where was that before was that like
area zero or something am I gonna have
to backtrack a bunch probably no in this
game okay oh I got a key boy that was
easy
but this seems also like a door this
seems like a room I've been in before
why does it seem like a room I've been
in before wasn't there wasn't there a
train barrel wait no I have wait I've
what wait
I've been oh that's what that door was i
I commented on that I said hey that door
that door I could have sworn that I've
seen that door before or III wondered
why they put a door there and they
wouldn't let me unlock it if it didn't
have the option but this was the option
this is the big room why would I was
there any reason that I would want to go
through here I mean I know I unlocked
area too but also why is this even
possible to go over here no it's locked
now see haha okay so you're not you are
definitely shuttling me through area one
two and three so these are all places
that I've seen before on my way to area
for which is what I'm trying to get to
to get the last music box wherever the
hell I'm getting these music boxes now I
don't know what that's all about but
train station that's what it was I
remember that of course oh all right eat
too and confirm go alright and then we
just travel area tea
we're an area to know where this is
gonna be there's a good question because
I realized the area one actually was in
Chapter two
I'm pretty sure anyway Oh some library
would there be a library wherever the
held area to is no god it's amazed to
all right whoa found it can't hide from
me baby I'll find it right away cuz I'm
so smart my big brain hunted out my
sniffer sniffer really knows exactly
where I'm going or I guess it wasn't all
that hidden in the first place so I
guess I shouldn't be too proud about it
but I'm still gonna be so what does this
key go to is the question this door over
here would that be obvious huh yep okay
it's the door oh where am I now
hello oh nice wall of piss
okay unlocking area three I guess oh hi
every three unlocked great good that's
good for me what are you doing though
what are you doing hello hi home movie
time okay I'm down boot it up let's go
hope it's flubber oh I'm back okay
welcome back hey how you doing your dad
my dad that you do you mean you are dead
uh-huh excuse me you need an apostrophe
re on that
oh oh oh [ __ ]
okay listen dot oh [ __ ] I got I got got
oh I've been got I got got all right
whatever
listen and nobody breaches you hard as I
preach you lose any of you oh where am I
oh all areas unlocked okay so oh that
was just guaranteed death oh all right
then
great good great awesome I'm in the main
lobby great good okay there wasn't
anything else
great oh great good awesome love it hey
you know what train buddy of mine we're
gonna hippity hop on over to area three
baby area three all right let's do this
go baby go wherever we're going I'm sure
it'll be good and I'm sure I'll like it
wherever it is we are we there yet
oh yeah there yet area three okay this
might be the last area but I have a
funny feeling there's probably gonna be
an area for just judging by things okay
all right thank you
good to know that getting got didn't
stop me in any way and doll boy it's
another open area okay I'll just keep
going forward
well I can't okay I can't go okay what
the hell I'm boxed in and the invisible
walls are a bit much
hello Oh Oh can't go Oh can't go that
way
wait is this a place I've been before
why can't my white bun what the hell I
can't don't go here oh oh oh okay I had
to find the hole in the invisible wall
oh yes I like your taste in music cuz
this is a trash room I remember that
pipe but I don't remember the other
things being here okay good great golly
gosh
[Music]
not the best choices not the best
choices where's my dubstep come on give
me some of that please play bangarang
this place looks familiar though I may
have been here before
I know that jumping doesn't do anything
but I just feel like I need to jump oh
[ __ ]
Oh
aha okay so I need to choose what portal
to go through a fun fun fun for oh [ __ ]
oh no oh no oh it's up
wazzle oh it's a puzzle oh no I'm never
gonna be able to get nothing oh okay
that was wrong okay that feels like
wrong whoa oh great oh good good good I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
what I'm doing
I feel like I'm just wandering
willy-nilly oh yay or boo wait is that
good or bad
wait oh there we go
kam back in the here wherever this is
okay that goes back so if I go but that
doesn't go back right okay how about to
understand you if I don't even
understand myself
oh what the hell oh I made it I guess I
did it what I'd I have no idea I didn't
find a rhyme I didn't find the reason I
didn't find a why I just kept going
until oh no don't
okay just your exit that - we're done
with this note so let's try to achieve
the goal again don't let the corruption
stop you who's telling me that who by
the way who's telling me that you you
the corruption inside me out or is this
developer telling me that or is there
someone else in this game that's telling
me that their Studios are you telling me
that oh you got me again yeah you really
you really fooled me but I'm a
persistent son of tits so I'm gonna get
in there and I'm gonna get I don't get
that thing you ain't gonna stop me from
getting that thing I'm show y'all my
elbow drop you right in your red paint
you ain't good feet a lot of diggin once
I grab that thing out of your hand so
well you just open up why oh [ __ ] hi I
think I enticed him too much with my
threats all right so is it the same
thing it just looks differently right
I'm gonna take it you can't stop me oh
come on now Oh would you put me in a box
stop coming back no no I'm gonna come
back I'm gonna do it I'm doing it like
I'm scared I'm just very persistent you
can't stop me so I'm here eh you think
this is gonna stop me huh a box oh well
I'm not going to debug mode I'm gonna
show you who's boss I'm gonna show you
who is the boss we're gonna go in debug
mode I'm gonna change up all the code
debug mode oh no that's not what I
wanted
oops that's something else that's not
the main game that's not what I was
supposed to be I'm gonna go into the
dark place and I'm not gonna go into
debug mode because barely is not what I
want okay I'm gonna do it again though
you can't put me in a box nobody puts
Baby in the corner and nobody puts man
Baby in the corner
if you know what I mean give me in that
box again I'm back baby oh the floors
gone I know it's here I felt it
I've stubbed my toe upon it like
furniture in the nose yeah oh you miss
damn says who seven jamming four that's
a lot of numbers I don't feel like
reading all those okay Wow listen listen
you're being a little melodramatic about
all this it's not so bad come on come on
hello yellow yellow yellow yellow [ __ ]
oh it looks like the corruption has
stopped you but I do know a way out of
this just give just type get /give music
box underscore for wall in the game
this will give you what you need in
order to continue but only this thing is
the game a malfunction because of this
so be prepared for that not prepared for
that that sounds fine to me flash game
music box for you got it
slash
got it no did I not get it oh [ __ ]
access denied well screw you [ __ ] oh
that did not seem to work here let me
try this to debug this and also type /
music box for again okay all right you
got whoa
Who am I talking to you by the way
processing proceeded cool got it oh yeah
buddy yeah body your body your body huh
nobody nobody oh yeah buddy yeah buddy
nope oh you never even believed me
well I'm listening this somebody just
not you alright there was some other
words there but I didn't see that
okay I'm going back in hey whoa the
finale okay alright whatever you say man
it's looking for vengeance apparently
for helping somebody else look for
vengeance if that means any difference
wait what wait hang on
hope is within you is it okay I think I
did neither ok the finale
dad let's play this bad boy come on
let's do this mom what do you got for me
[ __ ] what a Bop oh hell yeah
we're in real we're in the real real
harness this is a door oh it's a box
alright the trees gone we chopped down
the tree built the door I'm very proud
of that final room oh ok you got it
buddy final room whatever you got in the
final room is what I'm gonna get hello
oh hi a lot of dust in this final room
anything else I need to know about few
more hippity hop for the final room hipe
final room hype is everybody at home
hype for the final room alright this way
first or not being at the same room with
it guy was messing with me
corruption oh I don't know a code never
mind I guess I don't know that everybody
get hype get I provide a room wait wait
oh wait no never mind
I don't know this oh what a lovely
balcony you expect me to throw myself
off of it or something
there's the flowers I saw in the very
beginning of the game yeah what's with
all these like little knickknacks these
ornate things what are they why are they
here where am I going oh [ __ ] I don't
know what's backwards or forwards this
is just a big maze the weirdly oblong
shapes doesn't make any sense there's no
direction do it oh god it's another
where we're am I going it I'm gonna get
lost in here it's just as big as a
forest okay fine then man I'm only being
propelled forward by Shirky okay Wow
sure curiosity why was there an
invisible wall what is this I have no
idea this is like by design just this
weird okay found a key but so by design
this weirdly like open area that makes
no sense it's not amazed but inherently
it's confusing and here's a door that
needed a key that was Oh requires a
different key oh I love backtracking
what is the point because I know that
the game developer here is is not just
making bad level design for the sake of
bad level design it's gotta mean
something right there's got to be some
theory to it there's got to be some
method to the madness it wouldn't just
exist to exist
there's a reason this key goes back to
unlock something all of this like the
game in and of itself being corrupted as
part of the design of it right can't
just be nonsense
I can't go through with this then where
does it
where does this go where does it go oh
my god oh here no there okay got it I
thought it went through there though oh
I found another key great a key to get a
key this must be to the one all the way
[ __ ] over on the other side of the
universe which probably is gonna open up
a door that's gonna give me a cold but
it's all gotta have method there's
method to this madness I know there is I
wouldn't just believe that it's just
these big open rooms for no reason
there's a reason I'm gonna find out why
I think it's like folly my inherent
desire to explore every nook and cranny
is what's working against me because a
lot of these things are much more
straightforward than you'd think
okay ah another portal door another
balcony another door why where do you go
why was there a portal there oh I'm in
the real anyway where did the portal go
then should I go back for the portal
what are you oh hey congratulations
you've reached the end of the game but
there was a portal back there now leave
by pressing the Escape key before I do
that for you so tip 2 you can leave the
game at any time by pressing the Escape
key that's tip number 2 tip number 1 was
avoid the train oh my god framerate is
just taking a nosedive over here I'm
gonna go back I see the choice didn't
matter anyway no need to go back wait so
goodbye but wait my my no don't wait no
a lie trick I knew it why you still here
like my frames are [ __ ] garbage I don't
have permission anymore to quit the game
this level is locked from that
okay but I still have permission to
other things such as this FPS counter
what's wrong since there's not much here
won't need to edit some stuff for you
sure go I guess go for it
do your thing it editor mode Oh what the
hell oh I'm moving you're moving me did
you just move me create cube Oh
why would you do that
[Music]
Oh
what is happening
what is that right
Oh welcome back okay thank you
from that didn't want leave you all
alone so I've decided to block you in
but the thing is I can leave now now
leave
oh and finally be free oh okay me too
man me too very funny very funny still
okay oh oh
SpaghettiOs oh whoa geez I'm finally
free of that place I can do whatever I
want
can you now I can do so many things oh
you opened up a web oh you can close
oh I can take control and use this
computer anytime I need to
oh okay all right okay I can even mess
up your keyboard buttons okay
hahaha you bored you stuck it stuck at
my computer and even delete the hard
drive of this computer what don't do
that don't don't
Oh reformatting well I feel like I feel
like you're not actually doing oh [ __ ]
this is your ultimate reward for
finishing my game with deleting yourself
just sit patiently until it's done it by
the way thanks for playing you're
welcome ha ha ha oh hello Oh
no no what I must continue you oh [ __ ]
okay
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
wha-hoo yippee I don't save that I guess
what I do do let's go back in I guess
play game ok I'm going back in this is
gonna be great the true ending oh ok
good at least it's labeled as thusly oh
it's beautiful
I'm back in the forest though so I don't
like it it's beautiful well whoo yay
this is so true this ending that I'm
seeing in front of my eyes is very true
ok does this field literally just go on
forever cuz that's that's the opposite
of cool there's a hill here maybe am I
supposed to go towards the what is is
there anything here is anything here is
there anything here this is what the
true ending is is this is just this an
ice field I think I'm about to hit a
wall looks like I might hit a wall yeah
looks like a wall or oh it's a wall ok
well I found the other wall frickin
Frick alright I guess there's nothing
here it's just a big-ass empty field
okay let me try I'm gonna quit out I'm
gonna go back in I'm gonna see if
something else is there
am I missing something is that really
the end of it is just the end of it
you're not even gonna give me like a
narrative of something is just gonna
have me wander in a field try to guess
me lobby there's nothing else here song
of vengeance this is back in and out
that's it
he's backing it out there wasn't like
another building over there that was
Anna door I mean maybe there is a door
somewhere but you know how long it would
take me to circle this entire block
longer than I'm willing to actually try
I don't know I don't know that can't be
it
uh that can't be it that can't just be
it they're gonna leave me like that I
went through all that you're not even
gonna explain to me anything are you
really and you changed my desktop
background oh no oh no edit save file
whoa okay decide has two options picture
and terminal what is what is this load
secrets obtained by falling off the map
in Chapter one I got that one came by
entering the hidden door in the
recording room I guess obtained rarely
at startup uses random what I didn't get
that one obtained by using the code to
407 in the on the door in the final
scene code found my co-op multiplayer
online minigame in the chapter three
fours what
oh that's it's oh that's what that was
Oh team by restarting the game at intro
dream unity - ah I knew secrets unused
as it was used already in my place
unused so it's used hello
oh [ __ ] it's doing the thing would you
like to see a secret scene space okay
are you sure yeah you may lose unsaved
data if you continue well I mean the
games already over so and something bad
may happen yes okay
detected the type of door virus scan it
sure you've received a Trojan oh oh
you've done it I done it now I sure did
done it I've done two zhilie let me
corner you no no come on I've done
doodled you I've done it now I'll marry
you
doll you do scamp's okay boss [ __ ] now
that is it that is it isn't it god I
three go nearly three hours reset
everything
oh no we reset everything it reset
everything
No Oh No get debug mode we're gonna edit
save file good ending route what was
what was the pose the option fake ending
dot unity bad ending run good ending
around finale true ending game done dot
unity fake ending that unity wait then
what was game done died unity what was
that wait okay Oh is this
is this was this just this is okay this
that's the same thing that's that's what
that was
okay then what was where's the fakin so
that's just like the game's done well
here it is what is fake ending the very
last option and this is just fake what
the [ __ ] what the hell oh okay oh I see
you roaming around looking where to go
yeah kinda trying to find some well I
created this map just for you who did it
who oh hi as you can see well have fun
thank you and thank you for playing my
game ah
so oh yeah I almost forgot one more
thing what was that show ending Dex you
have achieved the fake ending and I need
some goddamn explanations out of this
I'm not leaving it like this I need some
[ __ ] answers you better give me some
goddamn answers pal okay so if I went
through I believe I probably went
through the quote unquote good ending
route finale true ending that unity game
done maybe finale true ending this oh
[ __ ] oh this is that sequence okay so if
that's what that was because I should
have gone that portal before it goes to
user then what was the
the bad ending let me go the bad way
what was the bad the portal was the bad
the portal would have been wait was that
all it needed to go bad was the portal
the portal was all you needed to go the
quote-unquote bad ending they cannot be
serious oh I get it
Oh depending on which world you're in
congratulations you have reached the end
of the game oh my god now leave by
pressing the Escape key before I do that
for you that's what it's all about
that's what it was all about it was
whether you went into it in the real or
in the not real
I see the choice didn't matter anyway
it's the same thing
okay so goodbye close game okay so it
actually closes the game and then what
then where does it leave it I get it
that makes sense
okay all right I get it
so with that I don't think there's gonna
be I sadly sadly I don't think there's
gonna be a satisfying ending to this I
think it's just these two things which
is so disappointing because there was so
much to love about this oh man and
that's what that is that's the fake
ending and when the game has just done
the game is just done in a lot of ways
the fake ending is the same thing as the
good ending which is sad but there you
have it that is the end of this game a
dark place this was really really cool
but there was just some weaknesses in
the level design and it's like there's
so many cool things going on with it
with all the things it does to your
computer that's so cool and yet there
was just a little
bitte oh there was just a little bit
there that I wish existed but with that
being said thank you everybody so much
for watching you can check out this game
for yourself you can get to this menu
it's just as easy a pressing one button
so if you want to explore other things
that I may have missed some secrets that
I may not have seen then you guys can
check it out for yourself I'll leave the
link in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know we thought down in the comments and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]